100 layer lasagna
do you think that alvin's going to be
able to do it
if anyone's going to do it it's going to
be alvin there's no way it's impossible
if anyone can do it
alvin can do anything i feel like my
whole life has led up to this point
today
we're making the 100 layer lasagna it's
going to be great i'm a little nervous
100 layers there's a lot of layers i've
never made this before it's kind of a
crazy idea and hopefully it goes well
oh i forgot my concealer oh i need to
put on hold on
no i need to put on concealer hold on
the ladies at sephora were very patient
with me
well i learned how to do this not going
to get on the food i promise
but
you know got to take care of these hands
because i throw them a lot the idea for
the hundred layered lasagna kind of came
from an internet challenge it was kind
of like this 100 layers of makeup 100
layers of clothes and you know we were
at tasty so like why not do 100 layers
of food and lasagna was the first
layered food that came to mind
so instead of doing the usual ricotta
mixture and a chunky meat sauce i went
for a thinner meat sauce and a bechamel
because when i assembled the lasagna
this is going to help keep those layers
nice and smooth
when i'm done this will have 50 layers
of noodles and 50 layers of sauce for a
grand total of 100 layers
the biggest hurdle with this is going to
be its size and how it is contained
because there's no baking dish that can
fit on a 100 layer lasagna and you know
you could definitely go and maybe get a
custom metal pan but
to do this at home i wanted to see how
you can maybe customize or macgyver
regular baking dishes to fit this it's
going to be really tall and definitely
figuring out how to bake it
while maintaining its height and size
was the most difficult part i thought of
using foils and lasagna noodles to sort
of hold the foil up and to make these
like four walls to contain the lasagna
while it baked and i hope it works so
we'll start with the pan as a base and
as the lasagna gets taller and taller
and taller we're gonna put the walls in
to help keep it in place
each layer needs to be extremely level
and extremely smooth guys i think i lost
track i'm at like five then we have a
piece of paper and a pen it's almost
like jenga if you do it all one way the
lasagna might split down the middle but
if you can alternate them it'll create
this interlocking pattern that'll help
them stay more stable when you cut it i
just put the foil walls on because i
want to make sure it doesn't like
collapse i feel like you should name
this thing but i would feel bad about
naming my lasagna because then
i would cut it open
and it would be eaten by like 500 people
i think george would be nice but spelled
s-j-o-r-s
41 ladies and gentlemen 41. i would make
this for
a really big party if i'm really trying
to like
show off to a bunch of fancy people i
don't know i also just might make it for
lunch don't get lost in the sauce kids i
think we're in a good spot i'm not gonna
lie it's like still not even over the
edge and we've only got seven more so
i'm feeling pretty good about this you
know it could just totally collapse and
explode and you know then it's not all
good
[Music]
oh my god it's so heavy please
don't trip
that boy look at her go
look at that the rack is bending from
the weight of it the rack is bending
claire
what's happening his lasagna is so heavy
that it's bending the oven rack
can you not put two right on top of each
other ooh alvin put two racks on top of
each other
massive
oh my lord
all right it's still bending a little
bit attempt number three
there we go
see you in an hour
that oven's hotter than my mixtape
so it's been an hour i think it's ready
i took off the foil halfway
[Music]
oh my god it smells so good oh
my boy george right there look at this
the walls are holding up pretty great so
i'm very happy with the success of this
[Music]
oh man look at that that's pretty
freaking awesome
smells so good i can't wait to eat you
hmm
take it out put on the board
take it out
put on a board cut it
it's pretty tough i haven't thought
about this part yet
so they put the handles there so you
could like lift it out
but it seems like some of the sauce is
like making it stick
come on george
[Music]
come on george get out of there
guys i can't get it out
[Music]
oops
well it's just one piece
george is being a little stubborn right
now
come on dude
[Music]
the sauce like made the foil stick to
the pan
[Music]
so now it's like preventing me from
getting it out
[Music]
[Music]
describing as many flat utensils that
are made out of metal as much as i can
[Music]
you got it
we got onto the cutting board
the wild ride kids now it's time to see
what it looks like
[Music]
look at that once i removed the foil and
it kind of stayed in its own shape that
was a turning point because i felt like
that was one of the biggest risks of
this video is that if you take off the
walls and it falls over then there's no
point i'm so nervous holy moly
it's very soft which i'm very happy
about
cut number two
[Music]
oh my god
that is what i am talking about oh my
god
we gotta get official counter pierce we
need you to count the layers
the rules are
a noodle is one layer
and a sauce is one layer so just count
the noodles and multiply by two
49
50.
i'm counting 49.
50 what
i got 52 again what 52.
[Music]
42
48 49
50 51 52.
52.
and this is the oh that's parmesan no
but this was 52.
when i was given the news that it was in
fact not a 100 layer lasagna in fact it
was 104 i felt a little confused did i
do what i set out to do is overachieving
better is 104 cooler than 100. it tastes
surprisingly super delicious i think my
biggest fear was that because of all
those noodles it was going to be dry it
was very you know flavorful it was very
moist i was super super excited about
how good it actually tasted i think it
was pretty awesome to see people come up
and their sort of eyes just go a little
bit wide they're like wait wait like is
this it like it's is it actually 100
layers like did you make this like yeah
like something i thought about and i
made it and it turned out pretty awesome
[Music]
foreign